what do you think is it is it about the
machine story that works that was so uh
captivating for people
I think it's a I think I don't know I
really wish I I don't know I think it's
a good story I think it's a good story I
think everyone has something similar
that happened in their life where they
had a crazy night and that no one
believed and they told their friends and
their friend and and or they experienced
that with a friend like that and and
and I think
I think that's got to be it I really
don't know I think there's a part of I
think there's a part of the like our
community of con of Comedy fans that
were that early death squad that was fun
to watch
someone take something from the podcast
and turn it into a bit on stage yeah I
think there's a lot of that but I think
people identify with a wild crazy night
that got out of control that they've
probably had too I I think I don't
[__] know
you think Putin knows who you are
because of that story I hope so my
[__] hope so
I hope so that but there's there's a
part of me that that you got to
understand is like I'm not
I say stuff like that I'm sure there's
someone hears that and they go who is
this [__] narcissist you're like no
that's not it I'm just telling you the
truth like I understand what I'm
supposed to say well you know I don't
know I you know I I don't know that's
hard to say but I don't [__] give a
[__] about that guy I'm not that guy I'm
telling you everything that comes out of
my mouth the second it comes out I'm
gonna be 100 honest I don't know any
other way to live I kind of hope so that
would be [__] cool and I look I know
he's about I guess he's a bad dude I
don't follow politics done but it'll be
cool if like one day someone's like uh
he's he's on his computer and some guy
goes and he's like yeah and he's like
duh
and he's like and it shows it to him and
and then he's like a [__] this guy
huh it's not out of the realm of
possibility that uh Putin has watched it
and this this podcast is kind of made me
realize how like small the world is I've
gotten to meet some incredibly oh like
especially the interesting people like
that's I mean that's the thing where I
go
like it's gotten really crazy
the internet's really insane and Netflix
is really insane and the reach of like
people that like this is really simple
but like I'm a big fan of the show drink
Champs I didn't think in a million years
Nori would ever know who I was
and then he offered me to come to his
podcast and then when I got there he
told me he was a fan of mine and I went
like I remember moving to New York
listening to you and Capone like I'm
sitting there going wow
like and then and the phone calls I've
gotten since the movie came out and uh
since Razzle Dazzle came out have been
really insane when you realize
as much as I know about people and I I
like there's people I'm fans of that
don't know who I am that like that are
like they're like some uh pitcher in
[__] Florida that I follow the kids I
like I think it's fun to watch him pitch
there was a softball player in uh Tempe
that she do catching drills and I was
really into softball with my daughter
and we watched her Casting girls there's
a girl deglazer who me and my daughters
would watch her dance videos and then I
hit her up she's like you know who I am
and you're like oh yeah that's the way
the world works